it's not just their economic policies
that it's not just their policing
policies it's also their language
policies these people don't want you to
know the difference between up and down
they don't want you to know the
difference between left and right they
don't want you to know that two plus two
is five or four actually it's four they
don't want you know the two plus two is
four and what they really don't want you
to know is that there are differences
between boys and girls here's Kamala
Harris yesterday and my God this is
insane
good afternoon I want to welcome these
leaders for coming in to have this very
important discussion
about some of the most pressing issues
of our time
I am Kamala Harris my pronouns are she
and her I'm a woman sitting at the table
wearing a blue suit
and
look at that biologist she knows she's a
woman the fact that this gender nonsense
this pronoun nonsense has leaked up this
high
is crazy like it's really really crazy
and just remember about five years ago
when they were like 20 or 30 of us I
would include Ben Shapiro in that I
would include Jordan Peterson in that
there were just this small group of
people online who were saying you know
this stuff is real and it's going to get
out of colleges and it's going to do a
lot of damage we were all called
neo-nazis and racists and everything
else the New York Times literally put me
and Ben and Jordan Peterson and Milton
Friedman and Thomas Soul on the cover
and said we're leading people to the
alt-right that literally happened and
now you have the vice president of the
United States wearing a mask I don't
know why she's wearing a mask she's been
double waxed and triple boosted and God
knows what else uh and talking about her
not only her gender pronouns but what
color pantsuit she's wearing in case
someone's colorblind and you wouldn't
want to offend them in the oppression
Olympics pyramid